Albert Woodfox had four decades in
solitary confinement he was imprisoned
here man angola state penitentiary for
most of his life but it was an incident
a year after his arrival at Angola that
would change the course of Albert's life
a prison guard was found murdered Albert
believes he and two other inmates were
framed because of their affiliation with
the Black Panthers they became known as
the Angola three Angola three consist of
myself I'm a wireless who passed away
[Music]
you know John's Black Panther Party
while still in prison
we became active we campaign and we
various protests against institutional
racism sexual slavery brutality and debt
by security staff and prisoners upon one
another as a result of young you know
having a low level of conscience as to
what was going
on his 69th birthday after 43 years and
10 months in solitary Albert Woodfox
became the last of the Angola 3 to be
released
Albert's body finally followed his mind
to freedom I have four beautiful great
grandkids and I would like them to be
judged on their abilities you know not
ethnicity or the color of their skin I
had textures or physical features you
know I would not want them 10 15 20
years from now to be fighting the same
battles that I've been fighting most of
my life
[Music]